pas facile d'être confiné une deuxième
fois en moins de six mois dans ses
résidences lorsqu'on est autonome
à 87 ans ils vont pouliot président au
manoir de l'ormière en zone rouge
en santé il est confiné depuis le 8
octobre dans son appartement d'un peu
plus de 300 pieds carrés avec deux cas
actif et moins de 5 chez les employés
impossible de sortir en raison des
mesures de santé publique
voilà pas le droit de sortir du tout
même pas de l'appartement
il ne faudrait même notre courrier dans
l'appartement
les deux résidences explique suivre les
consignes de la santé publique et fait
tout pour rassurer les résidents
monsieur la capitale nationale précise
qu'il est possible dans les cas
d'éclosion partiel d'autoriser les
marches à l'extérieur sur autorisation
de l'équipe de prévention et de contrôle
des infections par courriel la direction
du manoir indique que le statut
d'éclosion partiel n'existe pas nous
sommes en éclosion où nous ne le sommes
pas le statut de milieux en éclosion
devraient être modifiées bientôt à moins
que d'autres cas ne s'avère yvon
pouliquen qui lui indique que s'il avait
la force de déménager il le ferait pour
ne pas avoir à s'isoler pendant 28 jours
14 le métier de mesures trop
restrictives
inquiète la commission des droits de la
personne et l'on vous dit pas parce que
vous avez 70 ans et plus maintenant
voici les horaires de sortie voici à
quelle heure vous allez aller à tel
endroit et quoi faire dans la résidence
et on commence à justement vous priver
de certains droits sur la base de votre
âge
parti à ce moment ça peut être la
discrimination basée sur l'âge à la
résidence jazz de lévis par exemple au
début de l'éclosion la direction a
décidé de verrouiller la porte de garage
de l'immeuble afin de mieux contrôler
les allées et venues de ses locataires
en situation
la réponse est claire oui on les prés de
liberté donc c'est anormal
mais on est dans une situation
exceptionnelle et pour des raisons de
santé publié le gouvernement prend des
mesures adopte des lois qui sont elles
aussi exceptionnelle le gouvernement
devrait annoncer d'ici la fin du mois
s'il étend ses mesures de confinement en
zone rouge passer son défi 28 jours et
si félix morissette boulud radio canada
québec